so I'd like you to please give a warm
welcome some of the folks you know her
here and some of the folks who come a
surprise to you
there's a man who had a terrible problem
on his hands which was how the hell he
was going to make all of his work I and
I'm so glad that he did such a wonderful
job he saw our showrunner and our head
writer Marco Ramirez
[Applause]
I there's not a whole lot I need to tell
you other than she plays Colleen wing
just goes here
[Applause]
anyway I was newly received mmm wall
[Applause]
whatever oh yes we're doing that I will
have a lot to talk about today
she broke Matt's heart and then broke
all of our hearts
I Elodie plays electron
[Applause]
I'm going to ask all of you because you
were so kind to me that there's a real
reason that you should ever get out of
your seats
she is the just the first lady of
everything could you please stand up and
give a warm welcome Sigourney Weaver
just taste and even as the following
people are going to come out then go
plays iron fist
Walter please Kiki
Christine plays gently down
[Applause]
I got her kick it all off word chronic
knock please yeah
and the good folks at Netflix would very
much appreciate if now you took as many
pictures as you'd like and you have
tagged them hashtag defend please take a
seat I think you all know that we've
been incredibly fortunate to have our
friends at Netflix not just order a
season two but a season three of
daredevil I think you know that
currently in the city of New York and
I'm so glad that they both could get on
a plane in order to be here because they
literally were working last night in New
York Krysten Ritter is doing season two
of Jessica Jones my folder is doing
season two of Luke age and I am proud to
announce something that none of them
know and that is we will start
production on season two of iron fist
[Applause]
and I will give you one little hint that
a friend of Colleen wings may be coming
by and and that makes me a little misty
so we're going to kick this off Marco I
think the best way to describe this is
we took four completely different
television series of which you were
integral to two seasons of daredevil and
as someone mentioned today we it was
like taking four different jigsaw
puzzles putting them in the box shaking
up the box handing you the puzzle and
then taking the box away
how did you approach this what is what
did you hope to accomplish did you get
there
god I hope you did because it's done
tell us a little bit about making
defenders yeah the defenders was
probably the most challenging writing
assignment I've ever had in my life and
I think mostly because the characters
are also independent and because the fan
base is clearly all there for each of
the show's so the big challenge was
honoring each of those characters so it
never felt like any of the characters
are coming and visiting Daredevils world
or any of the characters coming to Luke
Cage his role but actually that
defenders was its own story and
self-contained so that was really the
big challenge and I think we did that uh
I think you did too good I think that's
super cool Jess you've got to play
Colleen wing in iron fist which was
obviously you had a tremendous amount of
fun
particularly when you were cage match
fighting and those uses go back and look
at it that's her in that cage like she's
just we couldn't keep her on the ground
so tell us where in defenders where you
you go because you have kind of issues
yeah I mean Colleen has really had her
whole life ripped away from her at the
end of iron fist her yeah sorry your
fault her sorry good father like her
religion her family her even her dojo
and so she we catch up with her own
Danny and then not in New York they're
somewhere else
and she really hasn't come to terms with
what's happened emotionally and mentally
and she needs to to move forward with
her life she needs to go through the
grieving process but will there be more
badassery from you yeah I with a lot of
being you awesome
or bad I guess bad buttery is what I was
looking for in Holly sorry I Deb
you where you you've had a you've had a
busy year with us and we're so grateful
you were bouncing literally at some
point you were shooting like defenders
in the day and going to Punisher at
night to just tell us a little bit about
what that was like for you yeah it was
interesting because you know each time I
do one of these other it's like three
shows now that Karen page is on and I
actually reached out to Rosario because
I was like how are you doing
oh yeah trying to keep her sort of
consistent across all of the different
shows and luckily the writers have been
so great and saying they want to put
their kind of extra layer on it but they
really wanted me to add in you know if I
felt it was right and so it's been
really fun to kind of keep adding on and
getting everyone's input is you guys
were I was wrong uh Elodie you're dead I
don't understand
no not we no spoilers for those of you
that have seen daredevil season 2 at the
very end she was put in a grave eye and
that would have been it but that's not
it is it no it's not and I'm really glad
that you know I think like tell us tell
us about Elektra in in this world
because it's it's not it's not who you
played before no and as much as you can
I guess yeah basically Elektra it is
amnesiac
she doesn't remember who she is and
she's trained by by Alexandra to be some
sort of a weapon and and I get the
question for my character is how much of
the Elektra that we know remains so
we'll find out I guess made in the
series when we will see I will tell you
a very short story when we first started
talking about who Alexander was going to
[Music]
Sigourney's name was mentioned and and
we all let out a collective squee
because that just sounded like maybe the
best idea ever
and I I spoke to Drew Goddard and and I
who had worked with her before and and I
said just tell me and he said the most
accurate thing in the world and that is
she's exactly what you want Sigourney
Weaver to be and it's just a class act
all the way from top to bottom and and
joined our what I always see is sort of
like we're just getting by and and yet
you came in and elevated it all I what
was it like when you first came to to
the defenders and you met all these guys
and well you you were kind enough to to
introduce me to them on stage at the New
York Comic Con loud fall yes so I went
there it was the first time or actually
been any literally walked on stage and
method for the first time it was too
late they were stuck with me because I
was already a huge fan of Daredevil and
Jessica Jones and all the actors who
play in those shows as well as by then I
was already a huge fan of Marcos and
Jeff's and the writing and frankly that
the character of New York City I'm a New
Yorker and and I love that knew that New
York City is indeed one of the five
defenders and they also offered me a
part I really couldn't refuse it's it's
a very interesting woman and a woman who
has a lot of dealings with this lovely
young lady and their relationship is
certainly one of the most unusual and
interesting relationships I've ever had
on screen or off so it was just a joy to
work here and work with you guys and I
really appreciate it and when what a
pleasure and what a joy be able to watch
then
season 1 of Iron Fist was sort of your
coming-out party it was like it was it
was you basically at you know it was
Danny first coming back to New York
realizing that he had to figure out what
his life was going to be but we leap
forward in in defenders and and you kind
of you're a man on a mission now tell us
a little bit about that yeah I mean I've
always them hi everyone by the way and
so I've always thought that season one
of iron fist and season one of defenders
was Danny's first full arc like phase
one and it was really nice to kind of
take Danny from the beginning of iron
fist and see him right through to the
defenders and see how much the character
changes along the way and really grows
into himself and he's definitely
inspired when he meets these other three
people with abilities to kind of take
his responsibilities with more purpose
and drives so yeah a very journey all
kinds of kick buttery as well sure yeah
Mike
uh what just like holding on Yokota like
uh you come out of Luke Cage uh you're
you're now the hero of Harlem I and I
think one of the things because I think
all these people have seen you get
socked in the face by by Danny ran and I
think they all know that eventually the
two of you are going to become friends
but that's not what this is about is it
no no and by the way that had even hurt
it wasn't you hurt his hand you know
this this story is something that we
knew was coming and I think the most
interesting part of the defenders is the
relationships between the people and you
know the fight scenes are cool and
everything but because we have such
clear points of view I think when we get
together on screen and we start to
bounce ideas off of one another and and
just have what we have off off-camera
it's great and so those to me are the
best parts of the series um I loved
working with fan loved working with
Kristen over here who have a long
history obviously and getting a chance
to work with Matt Sigourney you know it
just was a great cast and what was great
about it as an ensemble is that we all
shared the screen and we had time off
and we enjoyed coming to set and we
enjoyed seeing each other and we you
know who always remember that you know
Kristen
[Music]
ah how you doing
[Music]
you wouldn't think that Jessica Jones
would be comfortable hanging out with
other people that sort of fight for good
like she's got her own thing yeah how
did you approach it when you when you
knew you were going to have to be in
teams like for example with with Charlie
or Matt Murdoch what was that that was
like I mean obviously you knew Luke but
but matt murdock was a whole new fish
well Jessica doesn't really want to play
with others she doesn't ask or want help
but at the end of the day I think what
we love about Jessica is that she
underneath it all she does have a gooey
inside and she will rise to the occasion
and help the little guy so she
reluctantly goes on a journey with these
guys because she knows that she's
valuable because she's super strong but
she takes every opportunity to make fun
of everything they're doing and make fun
of daredevil suit and make fun of all of
it so I think JJ and the defenders
brings a little bit of attitude and
staff and and the funny
Sir Charles Charlie Charlie exactly I
can't help that Charlie uh you took the
biggest risk you were the first one
someone had to go through the door and
it was a big risk it was a big chance to
come out and be on the first show and
and you put that on your shoulders and
carried it did you know this day was
coming did you ever suspect that you're
going to work with all these people
obviously none of these people existed
when we started yeah I mean
theoretically I did
I do remember signing a contract and and
there were being some vague section that
mentioned a show called the defenders
and I was yeah sure we'll get to that
and then it just kind of happened so
quickly so it's kind of it's so as you
guys probably know you know each year
we've you know with daredevil than the
other shows we've we've been to New York
comic-con so it's kind of a wonderful
celebration that we get to come here to
Hall H I've heard so much about it I've
never been to San Diego and this is our
celebration we're not a team like
there's no leader there's no they're not
wearing like they don't go on at our
that is a big a on it or anything like
that so I don't get the reference just
to talk a little bit about the dinosaur
tuff of the show is that we didn't have
to worry about that did we yeah the fun
of the show is that this is not the kind
of show and I think if anybody who's
watched any of the four shows knows this
isn't the kind of show where they're
going to ever have a headquarters you
know nobody's getting fitted for suits
there are no t-shirts jessica is going
to look at Danny and say your fist
doesn't make any sense to me
it'll all yeah so we knew we had to kind
of come in on a very grounded level not
necessarily what one would expect from a
quoted quote superheroes story because
they're also independent and grounded
and organic and they exist in the back
alleys and if the big superhero movies
are happening in the skies these people
are all having fights in the back alleys
and in really shitty bars and bad bars
you